[Music]
in band this track yes and this track
submitted by Journey to the West where
sigh is that The Monkey King Indian
courts have banned PewDiePie's music
videos that targeted the popular
t-series channel wait wait here's
t-series parody music videos or
something yeah yes yeah yeah so
PewDiePie I was like a long-running beef
with t-series basically they're a music
record and like film production label
that's based in India the channel is
[ __ ] huge sorry I have so many like
statistic in numbers and I'm like
chiming in and I'm like guys for
reference this so the channels just
started creeping up randomly and then
when it was just a few million
subscribers away from beating PewDiePie
this gets on his radar because t-series
is about to overthrow him as the most
subscribed channel really not to say
that that's PewDiePie's claim to fame
but that's definitely something you kind
of want to hold on to he puts out videos
regularly so we kind of turned it into
like a little meme so you know it's
rally up his fan base as t-series like a
one-person channel or for reference on
how to series climbed up so quickly so
the United States has 320 5.7 million
people
India has one point 33 billion people
and it's four times the population is us
so the minute you start putting out
content like videos like the VEVO that
overreaches everything it's just gonna
generate subscribers views like crazy
when I went to their channel last night
there was a video that had just been
posted in the past week and I had 16
million views like there on some BTS
[ __ ] okay Wow just by population yes
even if everyone in Europe and the US
subscribe to pewdiepie we just yeah yeah
we just don't compete with India it's
the population is insane so he regularly
started doing videos like kind of
creating a meme and like pitting his fan
base against t-series and it totally
makes sense because if you get
overthrown as you know the biggest
youtuber at least you went out on it
being a joke and like you tried like
there's YouTube channels that it's like
t-series vs. PewDiePie you get to see
the lives
Treiber counts they're literally just a
couple hundred away from each other
constantly Oh Mike yeah people are
subscribing to him his fans are making
accounts and like subscribing multiple
wow that's amazing
yeah so he's been keeping it out there
both neck-and-neck see him I still on
the top thing there they're kind of neck
and neck like this while she waits like
every hour
are you team beauty power team to series
how do humans man for sure pretty sure
he paved the gamer way I wouldn't it
look I probably went to match all if it
wasn't for PewDiePie its double-checking
because you could look Indian yeah
PewDiePie put my response in that video
well I did a fine brothers react you
name dropping Raina Joe because I I know
about the whole thing right and so I was
I went I went to the reacting and then I
was talking about T series fine brothers
react yeah yeah with T series and
PewDiePie and stuff I was just talking
about like being OG YouTube and stuff
and like back then I think it was always
like vloggers and whatever that was
number one like from Ryan Higa to jenna
Marbles and whatever yeah and then now
it seems like media companies are just
gonna take over because the sheer
numbers of things yeah yeah and then he
was commentating on what I said and
stuff oh yeah oh you got the you got the
drop nice and even know I didn't even
know if fans just told you like yeah so
yeah he has been putting out some diss
tracks here's an example of one
pretty catchy the second one is catchy
[Music]
[Music]
why's ISIL taxi from like an Indian guy
hitting up a girl and she never responds
so she ends up responding [ __ ] lasagna
okay so he basically like he the the
meme is from this for this guy and he
was from India and you like you could
tell because it was Facebook message and
I said like something India and he had
messaged her and he was like please show
vision please Bob's in regime please
and then when shows in respond he just
responds and says so in India just
because you could see clearly that his
location was India so it's like all the
jokes but there are you know there are
certain lyrics that you know some people
were kind of like hey like what like
whoa what's up with this one of them was
he talks about a show it's a children's
series called malt loop Otley
he says multiple ooh what the [ __ ] is
that even supposed to mean
your language sounds like it came from a
mumble rap community so he drops like
some like white disses but you know for
the whole country yeah that's a lot of
people there so t-series they obviously
they they're a huge media company they
definitely have a legal team and
something I'm like you know what so they
went to the High Court of Della
Dulli is da like Delhi Delhi Delhi Delhi
Delhi they went to the High Court of
Delhi and they said that Felix PewDiePie
was trying to defame t-series so they
got a court they got a court justice to
determine that the tracks are abusive
vulgar and also racist in nature so the
videos are still up but PewDiePie's only
his diss tracks are banned in India a
letter if they're gonna extradite up the
process in the court of Delhi really
I'll be crazy it was funny cuz they did
the cease and desist for [ __ ] lasagna
and then he came out with
congratulations and congratulations he's
like writing out he's like you need to
learn what defamation means and he's
like suck my dick suck my balls my balls
still not defamation Kesha was funny oh
gee
yeah he's like this still doesn't mean
that it's defamation though like right
it said it in that same song I liked am
doing it it was pretty funny you know
you know that you could call people like
[ __ ] all this stuff yeah you
can't say that they are a scam or
something like they are con artists or
things like that because that's actually
defamation right yeah but saying that
you [ __ ] people's moms is also like
that's kind of like I don't know and you
could all see if you call somebody a
[ __ ] it might I would
immediately think like they're [ __ ]
my mom their mom but no one takes it in
the literal sense yeah that's right so
if you accuse someone as actually
[ __ ] their mom that's very different
from using a common you know phrase like
unless you're a Lonely Island
what did you call somebody a scammer
like say you publicly cost somebody it's
cameras above us and they try to sue you
for defamation but then like you can
prove that they're really a scammers you
can prove that then it's not defamation
but you have to prove it yeah that's the
point of defamation so it's like let's
say you you you make this false
accusation about someone and then you
ruin their you know potential for making
getting a job in the future or or their
business or anything like that you
spread a false rumor and then I think
that's that's the main basic slander
what's that one about oh you just talked
[ __ ] I think I don't know what slander
is I don't know the differences either
who knows deli knows what a major
doesn't apply as much to public figures
oh because because we're under scrutiny
from the public I constantly
yeah and it's it's very interesting what
a public figure is nowadays - yeah
because oh if I file a report and say
that somebody slandering me they're like
well you're on the internet you know
what can you do but then if I call the
police because somebody outside my damn
house they're like well you know you're
not in a there's like some Los Angeles
protection like thing that like people
that are really famous can get into but
like they're very selective over like
who they actually help and if I'm like
bro somebody's literally outside of my
[ __ ] house like they can't they won't
do anything like yours
misson oh yeah like it's like you're
famous enough to get slandered but
you're not famous enough for the police
to section a yeah that's why you gotta
get one of these finger guns
yep finger thank you
I've learned that the best I was reading
the other day and it was like the best
way to defend yourself if somebody like
comes out you and you feel threatened is
just to like get scarier than them like
just to like if they come at you with
the knife like say you're like in the
middle of like a traffic stop or
something and they get out the car and
they're like yeah what the [ __ ] man I'm
out of beat your [ __ ] ass you're like
yeah [ __ ] I'll suck your [ __ ]
eyeballs out of your skull like that
kind of [ __ ] people are like hold on
this is actually crazy did you learn
doesn't peers know I learned from a meme
I would trust self-defense right like it
would work
someone's coming at me I'm with a knife
I'm running you but I'm just saying like
if you okay then let's say you were
coming out somebody with a knife and
they started walking - I would stab that
okay no because remember we've talked
about like how to prevent you know
unwanted sexual things yeah and then
you're like well your sexual and
violence there's a little bit different
so a lot of sexual people they're
actually [ __ ] because they're just
like little dick flashes like [ __ ]
right so those guys are different those
ones you want to like you want to assert
your dominance on top of them don't get
scared they'll run away but if there's a
violent [ __ ] like that that has
a knife I wants to like rob you or
something I would probably run like 99%
of the situation and then if I feel like
I have nowhere else just alright then I
would just I would try to eat them after
you gotta bite them kick them or give
them a million percent raid I'm not
gonna box I'm gonna punch him in the
throat
Gaja their eyes grab their dick whatever
I could see that like the dominance
thing I think that's because I was
actually talking to like some friends I
was talking to some friends like a while
ago and like I've never like I haven't
been in too many situations where I was
facing like some kind of like sexual
harassment that I had to defend myself
against and then like the other girls
were like oh not so much me either but I
think it's because we're more dominant
people and the abusers don't think that
like they can take advantage
your pussy's yeah yeah so they go after
people that are a lot more demure that
they think won't like rat them out so
like if they come at you you just gotta
be like yeah
Oh [ __ ] yeah we're gonna [ __ ] do
this she wants it I don't want to give
it to her anymore
yeah that's like that's like those crazy
like rape murderers they sometimes
target like like weak little old ladies
they don't even make me horny right like
like who looks like a old lady and go
all that she [ __ ] makes me horny but
it's because of their weaker the idea
the way the walking and [ __ ] cuz I there
was a psychologist that studied the mind
of a rapist and what they what they're
looking for is to overpower women but if
she's if she's looks like she's gonna be
a difficult fight I'm gonna beat his ass
yeah they would study like women that
will come out of the grocery store and
then like go into their cars right and
then they'll ask like well they they
filmed it and they would ask the inmates
like well what do you think about her
like girl was hot as hell miniskirt all
that looking sexy and they're like nope
not a victim and then but then this girl
who was like unaware of her surroundings
just kind of like in her own head and
just like doesn't understand what's
going on looking looking normal like
norm wasn't like conservative and all
that yeah she was a victim girl hmm
rise up rise up you gotta be you know
[Music]